now thanks for joining us here today at
noon i'm heather mills school bus safety
it's something a lot of kids haven't had
to worry about after months of distance
learning but with so many recent
pedestrian deaths on valley roads the
school district wants to make sure the
kids know the abcs of safety kate
houston joining us from rex bell
elementary near sahara and rancho to
explain kate
yes well as schools focus on health and
safety inside of the classroom this year
they are also making sure kids are safe
on the roadways whether they're taking
the bus or walking to school
seir is be safe know the danger zone
that refers to the blind spot around the
school bus highlighted in red here ccsd
transportation executive director
jennifer vobus says the tires can
generate enough wind to suck in a
pedestrian and it has led to deaths in
commercial buses
as pedestrian hit and runs rise vobus
says this education is just as important
for drivers it's really important for
people to remember that school is back
in session and not only do students ride
the bus but they also walk to school
to slow down especially in the school
zones or if they see students on major
roads that are walking on the sidewalk
ccsd transportation continues to deal
with ongoing staff shortages vobus says
there are currently 240 bus driver
vacancies and they're actively hiring
we'll back out live ccsd rolled out the
ride on initiative with rtc a few weeks
ago to help manage resources now there
are about 1 000 students that are
participating 400 others have requested
bus passes reporting live near rancho
and sahara kate houston live local now